we're here today at Adelaide velodrome
with the cycling Australia team is a
massive year obviously for Australia
with the Commonwealth Games in their
backyard how do you prepare for that as
a team having a home games is always
exciting and everyone gets around it
everyone gets excited and there's always
more energy about it the passion for the
country is something quite special
I think it's on which we need to harness
and you know really use as a our own
sort of performance enhancer why did
cycling Australia's to partner with
science and sport we know that the
products are you know triple batch tests
that I think for us that's a really
important element of experience the
products before working in teams going
also back in the day in British Cycling
from my perspective it's got a great
quality product reputation science the
sport is a fantastic cell phone company
and ones that I use the most pretty much
every day is the whey protein and the
rego it's been fantastic to have that
there ready as soon as we finish
training institutions model I think
that's keep taking that next step and in
terms of being an elite athlete and
striving for any physical performances
things like electrolyte it's been
incredibly hot you're losing a lot salt
through your sweat and so just hydrating
you know really simple things you can do
before during and after your rides as a
sprinter you're racing so many times up
and down up and down for 14 hours
sometimes how do you keep that energy
going when you're not able to have a
great big meal yeah it is tough and you
can get caught with not eating much at
all because you have maybe half an hour
40 minutes in between races quick bars
and gels are perfect and finally but
most importantly who's gonna get more
medals Australia or the GB home nations
I'm gonna have to back houses on this
one we're gonna for come he say bring it
on
yeah Australia definitely I'm hoping to
come home with a few gold medals pretty
excited to have a big showdown this year
on the Gold Coast
you